[Musique]
allez bon important
oui salut à toi l'ami qui regarde cette
vidéo alors aujourd'hui et tulle a
peut-être compris en voyant mon intro on
va s'intéresser aux réseaux sociaux
à première vue on a l'impression que les
réseaux sociaux ont été inventés il ya
une quinzaine d'années dans des bureaux
californiens super funky
[Musique]
c'est vrai on parle de révolution dans
la communication entre les humains mais
fondamentalement est ce que c'est
vraiment nouveau
comme pour beaucoup de choses j'ai comme
un doute
est ce que facebook ou son équivalent a
toujours existé alors tout d'abord
qu'est-ce qu'un réseau social
pourquoi est-ce qu'il ya tant de
chercheurs et chercheuses qui s'y
intéressent alors rené si je peux me
permettre je pense qu'il faut faire la
différence entre le réseau social est un
média social
oui charlie on va y venir occupe toi
plutôt de ton propre épisode
ok alors aujourd'hui on va se pencher
sur les recherches de pierre-olivier dit
marc il s'intéresse aux plafonds peints
du moyen âge
l'équivalent au moyen-âge eu bien sûr de
notre mur facebook vous allez voir
immortaliser les banalité de la vie
quotidienne eh bien ce n'est pas si
nouveau on va aussi discuter avec cédric
sueur sa spécialité les réseaux sociaux
de macaques japonais
et oui il va nous expliquer pourquoi la
notion même de réseau social ne
s'applique pas uniquement à l'espèce
humaine
mais tout d'abord j'ai un rendez vous
par skype avec paula tout barreaux et
les spécialistes des réseaux sociaux et
des médias sociaux
on va voir si elle peut nous expliquer
un peu de quoi il s'agit des pour moi la
science s'y intéressent de très près
bonjour part au lard comment vas tu buzz
fait très bien mais s'il de cet appel
c'est sympa alors j'essaye de comprendre
quand on parle de réseau social on parle
de quoi en fait à en parler toi mais tu
sais mon chef des cartes tu as des amis
tu as de la famille tu as des collègues
et ses amis es
les membres de ta famille c'est connaît
surtout on n'est ce pas et mes ennemis
aussi ils font partie de mon réseau
social les ennemis aussi quand même
parce que nous aussi c'est son délation
même si négative
c'est un fait un réseau social c'est
l'ensemble de nos contacts et des
contacts qui sont un toi aussi
mais quand on parle de réseau social
aujourd'hui on pense à facebook twitter
ou myspace
c'est quoi c'est pareil donc en fait
facebook dont tu as entendu parler n'a
que ça en fait c'est un ensemble d y en
a entre moi et me contacter les mêmes
qui n'est ma famille mes amis mes
copains l'école de dévisser mes
collègues anciens et actuels et tout ça
ok donc ce que l'on appelle un média
social aujourd'hui facebook twitter et
compagnie ce n'est qu'une façon de
formaliser notre réseau social qui
existeraient de toute façon son
technologies
oui mais quand on parle de médias ou de
réseaux sociaux pourquoi ce que les
scientifiques s'y intéresse ben ça nous
éclaire sur beaucoup de choses sur la
sociabilité par exemple des gens est
sûre c'est ce qui m'intéresse à moi
aussi un particulier sur les ressources
et les richesses auxquels ils peuvent
accéder par le relation des ressources
là je comprends pas ben imagine quel
sens qui cherchent un travail
bah comment comment tu trouvé un travail
oui les annonces il ya les offres mais
il y a aussi les informations qui
peuvent dépasser tes contacts
il y a aussi des gens qui portent
décline lettre d'eric augmentations et
qu'ils peuvent dire à un joli mot à ta
faveur
ou pupilles étaient dilatées prize-pool
qui régatent avec un peu de faveur de sa
candidature
ces genres des choses et d'ailleurs ça
nous aide à expliquer aussi des formes
d'inégalités sociales
donc si on est bien connecté on a plus
de chance de mieux s'en sortir dans la
vie que si on est moins bien connecté
c'est ça ces gens des choses comment les
connexions en fait tu joues avec les
autres les autres facteurs qu'on connaît
l'élu passion les le capital évitez de
sa famille sa formation tout ça avec
tout cela les connexions jouent un rôle
non négligeable dans la détermination
des résultats de la vie des trajectoires
des lits des individus d'accord merci
beaucoup pour tes réponses et ton
éclairage on se dit à bientôt paula
bientôt aussi très bien si on veut
comprendre la société d'aujourd'hui
on peut donc étudier les réseaux sociaux
et les médias sociaux mais si on veut
comprendre la dynamique d'une société au
moyen âge on fait comment il faut une
machine vraiment
et bien cette machine à remonter le
temps c'est la science et le travail des
historiens qui ont récemment découvert
qu'au 14e et 15e siècle certains
propriétaires des corps est leur plafond
d'image assez étonnante
j'ai appris ça en regardant un superbe
documentaire du cnrs
c'est quoi ce poisson de police comme le
vire vers le film entier et dans les
commentaires allez j'arrête le suspense
voici quelques extraits
lors de travaux dans des vieilles
bâtisses on découvre parfois d'étranges
images peintes sur des clauses war
panneaux de bois coincé entre les
poutres et le plafond des scènes de vie
médiévale nous parviennent après des
siècles de silence
[Musique]
cette musique transporte à chaque fois
alors c'est quoi ces images tout d'abord
il s'agit d'une source incroyable pour
les historiens au lieu de représenter
des figures religieuses des figures
littéraires ou antiques
c'est le quotidien qui est mise en scène
comme sur les médias sociaux
et puis on s'amuse aussi ce ne sont pas
des images de chats mais deux bêtes
imaginaires
et puis on met des images qui feront
rire les visiteurs
cette analogie entre les plafonds peints
et facebook est prise très au sérieux
par pierre-olivier dit marc qui
travaillent sur le sujet allez c'est
cadeau je vous mets à dernier extrait du
film les maisons aux images
l'ensemble de ces images s'est très
largement ce que l'on trouve sur les
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui ou de la
même façon on met en scène nos amis les
valeurs auxquelles on croit les choses
qui nous font rire et donc on a
aujourd'hui cette conception disons
d'une d'une identité qui est collective
où on existe par l'ensemble de son
réseau social et qui donne à 100 se
rapproche de la conception qu'on avait
au moyen âge des réseaux sociaux et de
l'identité qu'on qu'on avait donc si on
passe beaucoup de temps collée à notre
téléphone intelligent c'est parce que
les médias sociaux nous permettent de
combler un besoin ancestrale de se
montrer de partager les choses marrantes
et d'exposer son appartenance à un
groupe
c'est donc un besoin bien humain mais
attention l'étude des réseaux sociaux ne
se limite pas aux humains pour en parler
je vais appeler cédric sueur il est est
au log
ça veut dire qu'il étudie les
comportements des animaux
bonjour cédric alors comment ça va
depuis la dernière fois
moi ça va très bien merci vous alors
j'essaie de comprendre ce que c'est
qu'un réseau social
apparemment c'est beaucoup plus large
que facebook twitter les autres médias
sociaux que l'on connaît j'ai appris que
c'est tout ce qui structure les
interactions humaines
mais si j'ai bien compris toi dans ta
discipline tu va bien plus loin
oui parce que du coup on va travailler
que chez les humains on va pas voir les
réseaux sociaux que chez des humains
hors des réseaux sociaux chez toutes les
espèces qui vivent en groupe en société
et comme on essaye de le faire pour les
humains on va essayer aussi de
comprendre un peu comment se structure
ce réseau social entre les différents
membres de chacun de chaque groupe
ok mais vous travaillez sur quoi comme
animaux en bois ça va aller des insectes
aux primates
on passe aux paroles les bâches et puis
y ait d'autres villes et c'est vraiment
chez toute espèce qui va interagir et
qui va vivre une société qui est
grégaire a vraiment le social d'accord
mais chez les humains on peut poser des
questions on peut étudier sa page
facebook
on fait comment avec une vache alors du
coup on peut pas forcément poser de
questions ça c'est sûr mais on va les
observer
ils vont y vont avoir des comportements
dits afilias tiff donc qu'ils vont se
rapprocher comme nous on se rapproche
et puis ils vont aussi interagir comme
on nous ment interagit soit avec du
toilettage ou avec des dt petit écouta
fidia tiff ou des choses à des choses
comme ça et puis après donc ça ça va
être chez les primates on va avoir du
toilettage chez des vaches on va avoir
qu'un peu toilettage un peu de deux
coups de tête ou de léchage et puis chez
les insectes on va avoir ce qu'on
appelle le partage de nourriture chez
les fourmis ou a vraiment de la
transmission de l'information de pata
pata
je n'ai mouche par exemple ok d'accord
mais qu'est ce qu'on cherche à
comprendre avec tout ça alors il va il
va y avoir différentes questions
déjà il va y avoir essayé de comprendre
un peu comment est structuré un groupe
animal et puis plus on va se rapprocher
génétiquement de l'homme que l'on va
pouvoir comparer et puis du coup on va
essayer de voir s'il va y avoir des
règles qui sont communes par exemple
chez les chez les macaques chez beaucoup
de primates on va avoir la même
structure en fonction du jeu du genre ou
du sexe et puis de là qu'on va retrouver
chez chez les humains donc
jeunes vont être plus ensemble et puis
même chez les jeunes on va voir les
mâles plus ensemble et puis les femelles
plus ensemble un peu comme nos enfants à
la récréation qui vont vite se
structurer en fonction des groupes de
garçons et des groupes de filles donc là
on va voir un peu comment se structure
le groupe et puis après on va essayer de
comprendre un peu comment la structure
de ce groupe va influencer d'autres
paramètres d'autres variables comme la
transmission d'informations ou la
transmission des maladies pour en chef
chez les humains la transmission des
maladies c'est des personnes qui sont
très connectés qui vont transmettre ces
maladies donc les enseignants les
infirmiers par exemple qu'on peut
vacciner en priorité
eh bien nous on va essayer aussi de
comprendre comment les connexions entre
les singes et ceux qui sont centraux
vont vraiment influencer la transmission
des maladies et par exemple pour le
virus ebola on essaie de mettre en place
des stratégies chez les grands singes
pour essayer de vacciner en priorité
certains individus et qu'est-ce qui joue
sur ce réseau chez les animaux c'est
comme chez les humains
alors on a des paramètres qu'on va
retrouver comme chez des humains ce
qu'on appelle la sélection de parentèle
donc on va être plus lié à nos à nos
parents voilà et puis après il va y
avoir des si ce qu'on appelle l'effet
prestige
donc certains individus qui ont vraiment
du prestige et à qui on veut être
connectés et qui vont devenir des hommes
des vrais mandé ne centraux au niveau du
réseau a assez des influenceurs ouais
c'est ça c'est des influences ce qu'on
va nous comparer à un youtube heures ou
des twitter merci cédric c'était super
intéressant
si j'ai bien compris il faut bien
admettre que nos besoins de se connecter
de s'afficher dépasse largement le cadre
technologique actuel
voire dépassent même les barrière des
espèces vos activités sur les médias
sociaux ne serait qu'une manifestation
bien spécifiques de ce que nous avons
toujours faire aller c'est la fin de
cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous aura plu oui mais
aussi mener j'ai adoré
vivement la prochaine épisode à bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]